There is a really, really crazy Christian
Trumpist named Rick Wiles.
We've covered them before on the show.
Some of the things we've covered are Rick
Wiles saying that vegan burgers are a satanic
plot to destroy people's souls.
He has said that Muslims have taken over America
hard to imagine, aren't they?
Like 0.6 of the population.
Uh, some kind of numerology conspiracy proves
that Barack Obama is responsible for the death
of Supreme court justice.
Antonin Scalia, uh, he previously said somebody's
going to die due to gay marriage.
Rick Wiles has said that Jews will use red
flag laws to take guns from Christians and
then kill them.
This is truly a religious nut lunatic of the
highest order he is now saying actually what
we've all been predicting for a long time,
if Donald Trump is removed from office, even
through constitutional legal proper means
like impeachment, there will be violence.
This is a, Trump is saying there will be violence
from Trumpists if Trump is removed.
Yeah.
Rick, we know.
Take a look at the clip.
If they take him out, there's going to be
violence in America.
That's all there is to it.
And when, when we say [inaudible], however
he leaves, there's going to be violence in
America.
And I believe, um, there are people in this
country, veterans, there are Cowboys, mountain
men.
I mean guys that know how to fight and they're
going to make a decision
that [inaudible]
the people that did this to Donald Trump are
not going to get away from with it and they're
going to hunt them down.
I'm serious.
They're going to hunt them down.
I don't want it to happen.
I don't want to see the country go this way.
But once hell breaks loose, if, if these people
in Washington think that they're going to
get away with it is not going to happen.
The Trump supporters are going to hunt them
down.
Veterans, Cowboys and mountain men who know
how to fight and they will be violent if Donald
Trump is removed.
Look at the victimology language.
The people who do this to Donald Trump.
You mean hold them accountable in accordance
with the constitution, right?
The people who do this to Donald Trump will
be hunted down by Trumpists with guns who
might be veterans or Cowboys or mountain men.
This is sadly, maybe the only time Rick Wiles
has made a correct analysis of something that
I can think of.
He's right.
I've said this and I will actually go even
further.
I believe that if Donald Trump simply loses
the 2020 election, forget about impeachment.
Forget about the 25th amendment.
Forget about any of that stuff.
If Donald Trump loses the 2020 reelection
campaign and claims that there was voter fraud
or fake voters or people voting illegally
or whatever, which he will likely do, I think
even in that case, Trumpists become violent.
Donald Trump has successfully weaponized ignorance
in a way that no recent president has done.
George W. Bush did it to some degree, but
it was nothing compared to what has been done
right now, and one of the outcomes of that
weaponization of ignorance will be that Trump's
followers will quickly turn to violence in
exactly the way Rick Wiles is saying they
will.
This is an unfortunate reality.
It's a reality of the political and cultural
status quo in which we live, which has been
escalated by Donald Trump's rhetoric.
The one semi-good argument I've heard about
gun ownership is does the left really want
the violent right to have all the guns we
need to get guns to, to defend ourselves from
the right.
Now, of course, in the real world, would more
guns really solve the issue?
It's dubious reasoning as we've exposed before,
but it is reasoning that I often hear from
pro gun owners of of pro gun ownership leftists,
which is the right is really violent and they
may get very much more violent if Donald Trump
loses or is removed.
Don't we need guns to protect ourselves?
Uh, don't we need guns to protect ourselves?
Let me know what you think either by replying
to this YouTube clip or sending me a tweet
at Dee Pacman on Twitter, how cans.
The question is, how concerned about violence
are you either around a Trump defeat in 2020
around removal via some other means, whether
it's impeachment or the 25th amendment or
Trump choosing to resign to avoid impeachment
or whatever scenario we are talking about.
What is your sense of the risk of violence
that exists?
I've actually had, I guess I can say I've
had some conversations with individuals associated
with law enforcement about this issue and
it is not an unfamiliar concern, at least
to the folks that I've spoken to, the, uh,
potential real physical violence that could
happen if Donald Trump, I'm trying to figure
out the right way to say it does not remain
president beyond January of 2021 because it
could, that could account for removal or simply
losing an election that he claims was unfair.
Let me know what you think.
I do want to hear from you.